so there is one question that if you're
doing a job interview you must ask this
one most powerful question and that is
if you had the power to change one thing
in this company what would it be here's
why it's so powerful number one it shows
you how much this person has actually
researched your company do they know
anything about your company do they know
anything about your business do they
have something intelligent to say of
what they would improve and number two
based on the type of suggestion they
give you it helps to identify if this
person is going to be a right fit for
you here's what I mean if they are
telling you something you can do on your
marketing or your strategy your product
your service or your positioning or your
branding then that might be a good
suggestion for you if they're talking
about your culture and something that's
wrong there then they may not be a great
strong cultural fit for you so ask that
one powerful question if you had the
power to change one thing in my company
what would it be hopefully helps you get
the next right candidate for your
business
belief